when Joaquin Phoenix when the Best Actor
Oscar unbelievably his first for Joker
at the 90 second Academy Awards it
seemed a bit like he was the only one
who was surprised the actor challenged
himself physically mentally and
emotionally to bring us the best screen
performance of 2019
although Phoenix famously didn't look to
any previous screen interpretations of
the Joker including Heath Ledger's in
crafting his performance he did share
one aspect of the late Dark Knight Stars
approach to the role
Phoenix found himself very isolated
while shooting the film for a couple of
reasons but one it was difficult for him
to simply turn off Affleck at the end of
the day in an interview with Metro the
actor said at the end of the nights
there was never really an end it stayed
with me every night after work for
another two or three hours I never felt
this moment of being done with my
workday I didn't socialize at all the
person I interacted with was director
Todd Phillips that became my world it
was non-stop Phoenix also revealed that
as a byproduct of his own strict diet
his opportunities to interact with the
cast and crew were even more limited
than they might otherwise have been he
said I also didn't really have a life at
that time
because I couldn't go out to eat
fortunately the role was simply so
stimulating for Phoenix that he actually
found these conditions to be agreeable
he said I want to say it was super hard
but it was so inspiring that as much
energy I put into it it gave it back I
would go home after work and we would
just talk about the next scene I was
just super excited I would show up at
set two hours early
just to sit in the trailer and talk
about it Phoenix famously lost over 50
pounds for the role of Arthur Fleck in a
wide-ranging talk with USA Today about
Joker he revealed that he's subsisted
largely on a diet of steamed green beans
apples and lettuce during the shoot this
was nothing new he had lost a similar
amount of weight for his role in Paul
Thomas Anderson's acclaimed 2012 drama
the master just because he had done it
before though doesn't mean that he was
in any way keen to repeat the experience
Phoenix sue disclosed that the same
nutritionist tasked with whittling him
down for the master returned to torment
him further for Joker said in all
honesty I didn't want to do it again
it's a horrible brutal
but you get all the vitamins and
minerals so you're like safe it's
grotesque Phoenix has been open about
the fact that the dramatic weight loss
had a profound effect on his mental
state and that he was able to use a
psychological difficulty it presented to
inform his acting in Joker if he had
been able to have it his way though
Arthur wouldn't have been the real thin
emaciated figure we see in the film in
an interview a month before the film's
release the actor told the New York
Times I thought he should be kind of
heavy Todd was like I think you should
do the real thin person his assessments
of the experience didn't soften over the
months after Joker hit theaters he told
The Times are sticking to the diet was
quote a horrible way to live
finding his version of the Joker's
famous cackle was a particularly
daunting task for Phoenix as a film
posited a unique take on that particular
trait Arthur's laughter is pathological
a disorder which causes him to burst
into violent uncontrollable laughter at
the most inappropriate of times parts of
Phoenix's method for perfecting his
version of the Joker's laugh was the
study videos of real-life mental
patients afflicted with this disorder
for a time the actor was reluctant to
employ the laughter but he simply wasn't
confident that it nailed it he explained
I think Joker is a part of Arthur that's
trying to emerge and I think that was a
really interesting way of looking at
this laughs but honestly I didn't think
that I could do it I would practice
alone and then ask Todd to come over to
a dish in my laughs because I felt like
I had to do it on the spot and in front
of somebody else it took me a long time
Phoenix has even said that to a large
extent he's still not sure if he got it
exactly right except in a few instances
speaking with et online he said I
thought at some point it would become
easier but I don't think it did it
became more difficult actually the actor
went on to explain that while it worked
for some scenes others were quote a
struggle saying sometimes one tape would
work and another wouldn't it just was I
think something that was alive in a way
perhaps the biggest challenge for
Phoenix in preparing to play Arthur
Fleck was also in large part what drew
him to the role an extreme sense of
uncertainty in the USA Today interview
the actor explained that the character
has an innate sense of slipperiness to
his identity
Lewton willingness to allow himself to
be pinned down as anyone archetype this
quality exhibited itself not only in the
pages of the screenplay but on set as
Arthur's characterization morphed and
evolved throughout Joker's shoot Phoenix
said when we were prepping for it I felt
very frustrated because I couldn't lock
on anything that felt like a foundation
for the character and at some point I
realized that was the points he was
unstable eventually though Phoenix along
with Philips on the rest of Joker's
custom crew found that this gray area
was exactly where they needed to be
he said it's shaky ground as an actor I
enjoy not knowing precisely what a
character may do but you want to have
like a couple moments that you feel
solid about and that never really
happened we just became very comfortable
with not knowing it was a singularly
unique approach which led to a
singularly unique performance one which
finally netted Phoenix a golden statue
which he probably should have been
awarded years ago in his acceptance
speech he told his peers we share the
same love that's the love of film and
this form of expression has given me the
most extraordinary life I don't know
where I'd be without her yessss only
fitting that this is so because Phoenix
has given us nothing but extraordinary
performances and with Joker an all-time
great one check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite actors are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the pal so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]